I would like to tell you in advance
that you are going to hear me say
the s-word a lot.
And you are going to hear me
say the f-word a lot, too.
So, if some of you are sensitive about
these words,
you may want to leave right now.
Okay, I'm going to talk to you
about success and failure.
What is failure? What is this f-word
that people talk about all the time?
I would like you to clap twice
if you think the things I'm about to say
would be a failure in your own lives
or in those around you.
Clap twice if you think being expelled
from school
and refused by other schools a failure.
Clap twice if you think studying
for three years a doctoral exam
just to not pass a failure.
Clap twice if you think learning
a foreign language for five years
but still can't speak
complete sentences a failure.
Okay, the first person that you might
have clapped for was Albert Einstein.
Is he a failure?
He is known for his success,
not for his mistakes.
But today, I am not going to talk to you
about famous people that we all know.
I'm going to talk to you
about Gary Green,
who most of you may not know,
and me, who you just met
a few minutes ago.
So when I was little, Gary Green
went to my school
and he delivered a speech about failures.
He is the guy who first introduced me
to look at failures differently.
He said that he failed
at his doctoral exam
after studying three years
of special education.
And even worse than that,
his wife and he had planned a party
to celebrate his passing of the exam,
but he was informed that he didn't pass
and needed to complete an additional year
of graduate school.
As you are thinking about
"what is he going to do about the party?"
well, I emailed him
and asked him just that.
He answered by saying it would be
cathartic to have a failure party
where everyone celebrated various
failures in their lives
and they just had a great time.
After hearing about this story,
my mindset completely changed.
I thought to myself not passing
exams were not the end of the world.
So now, I would like you to all think back
to our clap twice exercise.
Remember the last one?
The person who failed at learning
a foreign language for five years was me.
So would you all look at me right now
and call me a failure?
When I first went to Argentina,
a Spanish-speaking country,
I could not speak Spanish,
nor English for that matter.
I don't know how many of you
had the same experience as I did
when I first started to learn
a new language.
I needed to do a little Google translate
in my mind
before I could fluently say it out loud.
So as you can imagine,
my first few friends here were very
patient waiting for what I wanted to say.
My friend will ask me
what did I eat yesterday?
Asking about food is the hardest
question ever,
even harder and mind-provoking
than the question,
"what is the meaning of life?"
How am I supposed to know
this little green mini-sized tree
is called broccoli?
I would have to translate beans,
fried chicken and steamed broccoli
to my friends.
It's actually a wonder that we're
still friends after all that food talk.
Anyway, beyond that, I see native
speakers strolling through the halls
saying complete sentences
and reading a text out loud
as if they have practiced in front
of the mirror the whole afternoon,
while I first have to search up
all the exotic words
that I had never seen in my life,
click to listen to the pronunciation,
and repeat the word several times
to remember.
I remember for an oral assignment
for school
how hard I practiced at home,
but then when I came to school,
the things I was about to say
just couldn't come out of my mouth.
I also suffered because of my accent.
I remember how people couldn't
understand what I wanted to say
and tell me to spell the words.
So there I was spelling,
"h-o-w-a-r-e-y-o-u, how are you?"
Well that kind of conversation
would take forever,
so I asked my friends to correct me
whenever I sounded weird.
Gradually, people just stopped asking
me simple words like chicken or rice.
At first, I thought I was a failure.
Maybe I was just not able
to speak in public.
But now when I look my language learning,
I look at all the experiences I had,
I realized I wasn't a failure at all.
In fact, I was quite successful
in not giving up
and going to bed crying every night.
Here's a bit of an odd transition,
so just go with me here.
Never did I think that I would be
talking about my language learning
to talk about the founder of Spanx.
But, here it is.
Sarah Blakely was talking
to Forbes Magazine
and she defined failure as "not trying,"
but I tried extremely hard
to learn English.
So, in her eyes, I wasn't a failure.
Thank you, founder of Spanx.
Astro Teller, the head of X,
did a TED talk about his so-called
"moonshot factory"
where his team and he needed
to come up with solutions
to solve the world's biggest problems.
Did it work at first?
No. He said he failed so many times.
But then what did he do?
He celebrated his failures.
And then what happened?
He succeeded.
We have heard about so many famous
people, successful people, talk about it,
but what about kids?
The kids that you see on the screen
were in a class
where everyone gets
the same amount of stickers
whether they did well
or not so well on their exams.
Everyone gets a high-five
when they learned from their mistakes.
And things are phrased
very differently in that class.
They say they had an "oops moment,"
which I personally think
is a really good phrase.
So, you can't say that I didn't warn you
that I would be using
the f-word all this time.
I think TED-Ed Weekend is a really
classy and professional event,
so I would like to honor the cute
fifth graders
and use the oops moment from now on.
Hey, I haven't failed, you haven't failed,
we just had a little oops moment.
Just as Sarah Blakley, Gary Green,
Astro Teller, Albert Einstein and me,
every one of us has some oops moments
in our lives.
But however, instead of considering
them as failures,
what if we celebrate them?
Imagine a world if everyone
celebrated our oops moments,
imagine if we all have
an oops moment party.
How will we all change
and how will the world be different
at the end of the day?
I would like to see with a little bit
of an experiment.
I would like to ask the people
in the front row,
Hi, can you share an oops moment with me?
Flunking a test.
Oh, okay, did you learn from it?
Definitely.
Okay, high-five, that's great.
Hey, that high-five actually
feels really good.
So now I would like you
to turn to the people around you
and share one oops moment
and high-five them.
But just one because
I have a speech to finish.
Okay, so as I stand here
in front of all of you today,
sweating, even shivering a little,
I still consider myself successful,
even though I couldn't
fall asleep yesterday
and I might have messed up
a couple of lines,
but why should I care?
I'm doing speeches
that I was once scared of,
I'm talking to you all using the language
I wasn't confident in.
Failure? Yeah right!